[Music]
welcome back
okay so in the last few lectures i have
derived the wave equation
for a vibrating string like a guitar
string
basically from first principles f equals
ma physics
you get this second order linear partial
differential equation
and we talked about how to solve it
using uh separation of variables so this
is the solution here
i don't really care so much about like
the exact details of the solution the
things that matter to me
are that we basically decompose u into a
function of space times a function of
time
that's called separation of variables
and you get this kind of a form
and so i thought what would be fun today
would be to talk about what are the
implications of you know the wave
equation and the solution for something
fun
like slack lining so i know a lot of you
like to slackline that's essentially
where you take uh you know two trees
and you attach
a
uh like a rope or a cable usually it's
it's like seat belt material some big
heavy duty
material you attach a tight
line
between these and you basically tight
rope walk across it so there might be
some person here
i'll put myself on one leg
trying not to fall
on the slack line and so i think what
i'm going to do in this video this is
going to be pretty short i hope is just
kind of relate how this relates to the
wave equation
how things like the length of the rope
the tension in the rope the
you know mass of the rope or the person
on the rope all determine uh kind of the
motion that kind of thing
and then uh you know just pose some open
problems that you might find interesting
to work out as homework problems or just
you know to write out little solutions
or you know you can also
in the comments uh please just tell me
what you think about about these
questions i'm about to ask you
so we know
a few things we know that we derive this
equation based on
an argument of infinitesimal deflections
where gravity was negligible at least
the mass of the spring
uh the the string itself was negligible
compared to its tension
and that's certainly true if you take
this human off and
uh you just pluck this guitar string
this slack line it'll have a
characteristic frequency
that will depend on
the tension t
in the
in the line the linear density row kind
of how much it weighs per unit length
that will determine the wave speed of
the partial differential equation and
those information that information
in combination with the length
let's say that this length here is l
that tension the density and the length
l
will all go into determining this
frequency f
which is kind of the frequency in time
that that string will
[ __ ]
um if there's no human on it if you just
pluck that string and it starts you know
flopping and you can kind of picture in
your head i think this is really cool
humans have an amazing physics simulator
capability
inside your head
i have a condition where if i close my
eyes i can't actually picture
things objects but you can still kind of
in your mind's eye imagine and hear what
the
you know sound would make if you if you
flick this very large
uh kind of guitar string slack line
so question one is how does this change
when i now put a human on it and that
human has mass
so this human has you know mass m
and gravity is pulling them down at some
mg
so now the f equals ma that i use to
derive this wave equation is not
the mass of the little segment of string
it's the mass of this person
pushing down at the string on that point
so now the string is you know going to
be oscillating in the vertical direction
but the force equals mass times
acceleration that tension in the line is
not just moving itself
it's moving this person that has a mass
m and is being pulled down by gravity
with a force g
so i think now what we would have to do
is we'd have to modify
that
f equals m a when we derived this
equation and i'm guessing again this is
kind of a homework problem for you
i'm guessing we're going to add in a
forcing term
you know plus
something like uh
m
g and this is going to be a delta
function of x minus
wherever the person is standing x minus
x naught okay
so this is you know now i've added some
spatial delta function forcing
because this person is standing on that
that string
and i think what that's going to mean is
that the steady state is no longer flat
the steady state is going to be
deflected so that that person is being
you know kind of
pulled up by the tension in that rope by
the y component of the tension in that
rope
we're still assuming the small angle
approximation because you know if you've
if you've ever uh put one of these slack
lines together you basically use a big
ratchet lever system to get this thing
super duper tight so that a human can
walk on it without it just sagging to
the ground so you still have that small
angle approximation but now the human is
putting a massive delta
forcing
on this thing maybe this is a minus
mg because it's in the negative
direction
good
good good good okay uh
what else okay so
again revisiting this if i make the
length longer
that should
make this this l is bigger so this
frequency should be lower so the longer
the just like a guitar string if i have
a longer slack line the frequency will
be lower it'll be a lower frequency if i
had this thing spanning the grand canyon
i'd have a very low frequency
oscillation which might make it easier
it might make it harder i'm not sure
i think having too high of a frequency
would be difficult or too low maybe i
think also it's going to interact with
the resonance of the human so this is my
other kind of homework question for you
is that if you think of this human as
kind of an inverted pendulum i'm
balancing on one foot i don't think you
can see but if i think of myself as a as
an unstable inverted pendulum
then we know that an inverted pendulum
or like a grandfather clock has a
frequency
or let's say a period of oscillation
this human's kind of natural period of
rhythm
is going to be t
this is not the tension t this is the
period t
this is the t of
human
oscillation
is going to be proportional to the
square root of
g over l
where l again sorry l is not the length
of my slack line
l is the height of the human let's call
this h
h the height of the human
so the height of a human h
and gravity sets up another kind of
frequency uh which is you know whatever
um
related you know the inverse of this
period is the frequency
and so
you know this human
is oscillating when i'm on a slack line
i am wobbling
and i'm on the line itself and the line
itself
is
wobbling and it's wobbling in two
directions but we're going to simplify
it and say it's one dimensional
and when these time scales when these
frequencies start to get close to each
other that's when you get into really
nasty resonances
and so again
because this thing has
a sum of sine waves
at each of the harmonics of this
dictated by this length l string i have
that low frequency but then i also get
all the higher harmonic frequencies
higher and higher and higher and at some
point some of those frequencies may
interact with kind of the frequency of
oscillation of a human kind of
you know i think of a human as an
inverted pendulum which is kind of like
a grandfather clock which has this basic
period which sets up a basic frequency
and so that's that's kind of the next
question is okay well how do the
resonances of the human system
and the slackline system interact with
each other what are the frequencies that
are being excited for what length for
what mass person
and so on and so forth because also the
mass of the person presumably is adding
to the tension of the string so you
ratchet this thing tight but when that
person stands on the string they are
noticeably increasing the tension by
their mass so this t goes up when the
person stands on it that's interesting
too
what else um
what makes a slackline easier okay so
my wife's parents put a slackline in at
their house our kids love playing with
it
and so sometimes what you do
is you put a little guideline here
that basically you can hold on to above
your head to kind of guide yourself you
know so that you don't fall so that you
don't oscillate as much
but for example if you pull on that so
that you take some of your weight up
you're essentially changing the tension
in this line
you know you're changing the tension
because you're taking some of your mass
up
you're also changing your human period
of oscillation because you're changing
your effective gravity if you're like if
you're taking half of the
the force of your body it's kind of like
you're you're cutting g in half
essentially or cutting m in half
all of those things change the dynamics
of the slack line so that would be
another interesting homework problem is
for example
imagine i'm putting half of my weight on
this guide line
how does that change the resonance
frequency how does that change the
you know the the dynamics of the slack
line how does it change the dynamics of
my oscillation
all of those are kind of interesting
problems for example what would a
slackline look like if i was slack
lending on the moon would it be easier
or harder or on jupiter would it be
easier or harder
what if i was slack lending on a steel
cable versus a big nylon cable things
like that those are all the kinds of
things what if i could tension this
thing up a hundred times tighter would
it be easier or harder okay those are
all the kinds of questions that i think
you can start exploring in this basic
setup i'm not going to answer any of
them that's my prerogative
but i think it's really interesting to
think about
the wave equation this really can help
you build your intuition is thinking
about things like guitar strings or
slack lines or maxwell's equations think
about real physics and how that real
physics manifests you know as the terms
and these equations that's why we do
math
that's why i do math it's not the only
reason i do math but that's why we do
applied math is so that we become facile
at modeling the real world so that we
can
make assumptions and break assumptions
and we know what changes and we know how
it changes and we build this kind of
intuition
for the real world anyway i thought this
was kind of a fun one i've been thinking
about this in the back of my mind as
i've been preparing this lecture and so
i thought i'd just pose some of these
questions to you
again curious what you think in the
comments maybe some of you will solve
these or come up with your own problems
or maybe we'll get you know some expert
slackliners to give me some intuition
because i'm a terrible slackliner about
how to make my life easier all right
thank you